well there's still more scientific
evidence that Facebook and other tech
companies are hurting America and
distorting our brains a brand new study
by psychologist the University of
Pennsylvania finds that Facebook just
Facebook among many social media
platforms can substantially increase
depression in people and loneliness and
these feelings go away when a person
gets off of Facebook that should not
surprise us just a year ago early
facebook investor Sean Parker brag did
the company deliberately made the
study's addictive as possible without
caring at all about the harm it could
inflict imagine the tobacco chieftains
admitted that they'd be in prison but
walking free Tom Kersting is the author
of the book disconnected how to
reconnect our digitally distracted kids
and he joins us tonight Tom I'm not
going to ask you if you're surprised by
this because I know that you're not
because you're a little book on it what
is the answer for parents of teens of
young people who are watching their kids
slip away become remote and sad because
they've overused
well the number one advice I given am
lecturing on this topic is everybody is
we have we've turned into a keeping up
with the Joneses sort of society where
everybody seems to be doing what
everybody else is doing so for example
the average age that kids are getting
their first smartphone is fifth grade
and I can ask any parent average that's
the average the average average child is
in fifth grade is getting a smartphone
that has all the social media and
everything else on it and if we ask
anybody that's listening do we think
that's a good idea as parents they're
gonna say no yet the majority of them
are doing it anyway that's kind of a
conformity sort of thing it is
conformity so maybe the first step is
saying out loud what everybody suspects
which is this is destroying our society
it's making us dumb and sad it is and as
far as the depression component alright
and I wasn't I was happy to see a study
come out cuz they're always looking for
a study and sometimes we need to look at
common sense when we look around we see
what's happening ya know the fact that
the suicide rate among teenagers has
gone up seventy percent since 2006 and
all of the research behind other
research seven just to please restate
that seventy percent since 2000 2006 so
survey among young among teenagers yes
that's gone up seventy percent the
researchers although there's nothing to
say
Stan she ate it yet but the researchers
are suggesting that that's because of
social media because when you're on
social media all the time
what are you craving what are you
looking you're looking for feedback
you're looking to fill an internal sense
of self yes of an external source and
self-esteem joy and happiness is an
inside-out thing it's never never an
outside-in thing and that's where people
are getting tangled up and they don't
even realize it so the cigarette
companies never killed that many teens
not even close right exactly you're
straight to get sick from smoking and
yet they got hauled up and barbecued and
basically federally regulated into near
extinction because of the threat they
posed to kids but nobody's doing
anything about this because why well
again it goes back to there was a study
that came out showing the dangers from
the radiation from cellphones in
California all right and when the center
of Disease Control came across the study
that refused to release the findings
there to go to federal court go to state
court in order to get the findings
release and we know what it's about
it's about big tech industry all the
money that's behind that the lobbying
and and and everything that they they're
not thinking about the well-being of the
human beings they're thinking about
their bottom line the people who should
be raising alarm are so caught up hating
Trump it's like they're missing the
story which is this is wrecking our
country mm-hmm you've been a lonely
voice in the subway every shoe come back
once again great I would love to thank
you Tucker